bonsoir à tous et bonne année bienvenue
dans l'émission à 6 ans par les sports
vous connaissez programme il y aura des
coups de gueule des analyses des débats
et des duels présentation de nos
chroniqueurs en musique ont commencé à
droite alexandre taillefer l'homme fort
du handball yvelinois nouvel entraîneur
de l'équipe masculine de versailles et
des jeunes de team 78 ne s'arrête jamais
il est de retour à l'est après une
émission d'absence de près il ya de
retour de prêt lui en veux voilà comme
en musique
mustapha larbaoui on passe à gauche
c'est l'un des présidents les plus
influents des yvelines le président du
real florentino perez ou vincent labrune
de l'om lui envient son charisme et son
sens de la formule
il vient d'être élu yves binois d'année
par nos confrères des nouvelles de
versailles je veux bien sûr parler de
mustapha larfaoui le président de
trappes
vous allez bien je me suis pas trompé
dans votre présentation sont à même de
mieux en mieux je trouve que vous auriez
présentation est magnifique donc ça va
de mieux en mieux mais d'un corset bonne
année à tout le monde un bonne année à
ma droite de nouveau il est dans le
rugby depuis une vingtaine d'années il à
ce sport dans le sens ni l'entraîneur de
l'équipe senior de plaisir depuis
septembre dernier
son auteur l'une des meilleures
formations du département actuellement
et c'est sa grande première sur le
plateau de si on parlait sports jean
miss est avec nous aujourd'hui pas trop
stressé pour sa première fois non ça va
aller ça va aller une bonne année à tous
une bonne année
alors autant à gauche musique s'il vous
plaît il est le spécialiste du sport
yvelinois on le surnomme l'encyclo
physique car il connaît tout sur tous
les sports et compléter des jeux
déjeuner en lisant les pages sportives
du département sont historiques internet
le prouve
il reste les règles de ce sport la nuit
il ne s'arrête jamais et vous le
connaissez sûrement si vous avez regardé
les précédentes émissions de 6 ans par
les sports qu'elle réalise sa chronique
j'aime j'aime pas je veux bien sûr
parler de basile rigoli la première sur
ce pad ce soir plateau s'est bien passé
très bien de la seconde ce sera ce
serait encore mieux on espère donc je
viens de vous dire à tous bonne année
mais si vous avez une résolution
particulièrement sera pas pour cette
année - par portif résolution celle là
celle là par un concile en l'occurrence
j'ai beaucoup de choses à dire cette
année aussi quand les dernières et voilà
maintenant quand on a beaucoup de choses
à domicile et terminer deviez
téléspectateurs en jugeront par la
qualité surtout alors on va passer
maintenant au programme de l'émission
aujourd'hui nous allons parler du jeune
pilote de kart originaire du chéné à
william bertrand de rugby avec un focus
sur plaisir mais tout de suite retour
sur la qualification de menthe en serre
entend deuxièmes de finale de la coupe
de france
on commence donc cette rubrique
résultats par du football le club de
menthe ces dernières qui pillent n'ose
encore en course en coupe de france a
créé l'exploit de se qualifier pour les
16e de finale de la compétition en
battant le stade briochin le score 2
buts à 0 avec cette victoire le fc
mantois équipe de cfa écrit l'une des
plus belles pages de son histoire depuis
sa création en 1994 le club n'avait
jamais dépassé le stade des 32e de
finale de la coupe de france
on écoute la réaction des deux coaches à
la fin de la rencontre sur le match on
ne peut pas se vanter d'avoir été au
dessus au dessus on a eu la chance
d'ouvrir le score un bon moment de la
partie à prendre a subi mais bon comme
ce qui compte c'est de passer des
regrets d'avoir encaissé ce but là parce
que finalement ils nous marquent le but
sur leur seule demi-occasion c'est même
pas une véritable occasion donc le
regret il est là félicitations mantois
c'est eux qui ont gagné et son passé
même si on peut considérer qu'on a été
meilleurs que sur ce match là mais au
final c'est eux qui seront en seizièmes
donc félicitations et la question de ce
premier thème mentent en 16e de finale
de la coupe de france
est-ce une surprise vous vous et et
messieurs vous souvenez rouge non verts
oui vous êtes partager un petit et un
petit duel entre bravo bien sûr d'accord
bombe en face et que la question fait un
petit débat un petit débat entre l'outil
dieu entre basile et et vous alexandre
c'est parti vous avez perdu aucun duel
en depuis hier suite à cette émission
par la pression d'être le premier duel
perdu par exemple ont commencé bah pour
moi c'est pas c'est pas une surprise
attendait qu'ils ont battu une équipe
qui était en dessous d'eux donc en cfa 2
donc la logique a été respectée voilà je
réajuste sa dire tellement court mais
efficace
@ il efficace je sais pas moi je pensais
c'est une belle surprise bien sûr
simplement parce que depuis la création
du fc mantois il ya il ya quinze ans le
club n'avait jamais réussi à atteindre
les seizièmes de finale ça à la dernière
fois que montrent c'était l'époque du ca
mantes-la-ville l'étain avait atteint ce
niveau de compétition c'était en 94
donc il ya 22 ans on sait la difficulté
de réussir un parcours en coupe de
france
c'est rare qu'un club amateur arrive à
atteindre ce niveau là il doit en rester
aujourd'hui doit rester cinq équipes de
cfa 2 équipes de cfa 2 donc même s'ils
ont eu des adversaires hiérarchiquement
inférieurs à eux lors des tours
précédents
faut quand même on sait que sur un match
de coupe de france il ya plus vraiment
d'histoire de niveau cfa cfa2 sa sgo on
l'a vu sur ce match je pense que oui
c'est une surprise d'attendre quand on
est un club amateur d'arrivée a gagné
sept matches pour atteindre les
seizièmes de finale au mois de janvier
ici tu es tout seul puisqu'il vient de
dire à juste titre qu'ils ont rencontré
que des équipes à faire depuis le début
donc ce qu'on peut trouver par contre
remarquable c'est la chance qu'ils ont
eue de rencontrer que des équipes plus
faibles qu'eux en terme de classes de
niveau de jeu depuis le début que ça ne
retire en rien le déficit est quand même
d'avoir réussi à battre les équipes et
qui n'est pas une surprise comme il peut
y avoir de temps en temps dans le foot
ou très souvent même mais mais bon
malgré tout ils ont battu quand même
l'équipe j'étais censé battre encore une
fois ils les battent et en plus à
domicile
je ne vois pas où est la difficulté et
où ils ont eu des difficultés à la
probabilité de voir un club de cfa
atteindre les seizièmes de finale quand
il commence la compétition allait faire
4e tour je suis d'accord elle est viable
la consulter dans des vents plus faibles
d'avoir rencontré que des équipes en
dessous de leur niveau et c'était leur
cas donc pour eux pour une hausse et
eiffage aurait dit c'est peut-être une
surprise mais pas pour vu leur parcours
mostafa tranche est dangereux non je
prends une rage je vais pas tranché mais
il faut trancher
non je veux pas trancher pour une seule
fois une seule chose c'est que
techniquement il a raison randonnée
techniquement il a raison quand on joue
des équipes d'un niveau inférieur c'est
pas moi qui vais dans le contrat juteux
sur soutenu ici quand on est premier on
reste premier quand on est à un niveau
supérieur on marque la différence et
c'est le propre du sport c'est le propre
de la compétition techniquement la
raison simplement on est en coupe de
france et chaque match de coupe de
france et un quasi exploit que c'est pas
un exploit de bahts une cfa2 quand on
est en f1 mais ça reste ça demeure un
historique
c'est de ça dont on parle en fait c'est
le côté historique deuxièmement la
chance fait partie du sport donc ils ont
effectivement cette chance d'avoir quand
même des clubs d'un niveau soit
inférieure soit égal on a eu des dh avec
des dh à un moment donné donc
techniquement il a raison ça demeure
historique
c'est en ce sens où j'aurais plutôt
tendance à dire oui je suis j'aurais
plutôt tendance à a tranché du côté de
notre ami basile
sauf que techniquement on peut pas dire
le contraire et enfin pour terminer
moi j étais je parle a justement vous
dire que je ne suis pas un théoricien du
sport moustapha je suis pratique je suis
sur le terrain je mouille le maillot
j'y vais moi je vois bien cela bien
alors qu'en réalité l'homme de terrain
c'est moi et notre ami bhatti qui était
aussi on peut dire de quoi on parle
la première mi temps vous parliez
première ça va vous parliez compensée
par les prendre mais ça va vous parliez
de terrain justement là les images de
moi deviner
voilà un homme de terrain personne ne
voit la personne de terrain et amateurs
de frites nous appartient olalala les
bonnes résolutions pour 2016 ça les prix
alors en réalité arrêtée je vous faisais
que transporter les frites ce soir
j'avais près de deux copains qui avaient
pas manger mais je chausse de modifier
ce codec est un jeu d m'y attendais a
glissé pour moi c'est juste que le droit
à l'image n'a pas signé pour ça vous
n'avez pas si mes défier pour cette
émission finir je tiens à le dire c'est
mon kiff à chaque fois des terrains de
football va manger des frites et les
merguez il y en avait plus il ya un
monde fou pull fritz pour vous dire le
niveau d'excellence et et le public
présent à la première à vis de savoir
faire
mais pour terminer quand même on revient
du moteur vous y étiez pour être pour
être le simple j'aime beaucoup
d'occasions il faut être plus sérieux la
première mi temps il était totalement
tétanisée
on a vraiment le sentiment que ça jouait
pas du tout pas simplement le sentiment
des gens ça ne jouais pas il était
tétanisé il était même clairement on
voyait bien qu'il avait donc la trouille
donc il ya bien l'enjeu pour tang cfa2
donc la trouille au ventre ils l'avaient
ne sachant pas ne trouvons pas les
occasions ne trouvant pas la manière
dont ça s'est joué c'était favoris et
c'est tout à fait normal que la
normalité elle est quand même là on veut
bien considérer qu'elle soulevait faire
quand même favoris oui que parfois c'est
mon c'est mon discours de toujours mener
le jeu autant d'écart on est incapable
sauf que la première mi-temps pour ce
qui était notre âne je confirme
c'était complètement bloquée et ça s'est
débloqué à la mi-temps 1-0 et puis le
deuxième but bien sûr il arrive à la
toute dernière seconde
père sur une carte d'accord sur un
corner où les bretons font le forcing
stato à fait d'accord avec avec son
analyse façon on regarde les
statistiques chez pas que manger des
fruits monde ça a été deux tirs cadrés
sur ce match deux buts
si on parle vraiment de tir cadré il y
en a eu 2 2 au fond du côté de saint
brieuc il ya une dizaine d'occasions il
ya eu un très bon très bon malick guèye
dans les buts du fc mantois qui a permis
de garder son équipe
dedans à l'issue de la première période
mais pour moi c'est pas un argument
parce que ça à chaque fois qu'on me dit
ça au foot ça sous-entend que gad un but
n'est pas censé arrêter des ballons ça
moi ça me tue - le ghana bus et ses
rôles ainsi boxe ici le gardien de but
il a fait des arrêts bravo aux gars et
j'ai envie de dire que ce soit la
première période sa dette était l'unique
joueur ou l'un des rares joueurs du fc
mantois ait vraiment rentrer dès la
première minute dans cette rencontre
mais très bien et leur mandat voilà
c'est sur l'analyse du web alors quoi
l'organisation
deuxièmement si on pousse le
raisonnement le lui disent devoir
marquer absolument et tout le temps le
gardien de va pas refaire de non c'est
juste un match de foot c'est 82%
celui qui fait le but par contre c'est
quand le gardien de but i feel ans et un
an mais on les sondes mais on met en
avant quand il est bourru particulière
mais pas en avant mais il est bon vous
allez vous avez mis en avant que
l'occasion moi je mettrais en avant
plutôt qu'ils ont ils ont fait des
arrêts le gardien de but a fait des
arrêts il faut lui qui est là pour ça
donc en tout cas menthe est qualifié et
au prochain tour ils affronteront nantes
une équipe de ligue 1 donc le 20 janvier
prochain en 16e de finale donc de la
compétition ça explose est-ce qu est-ce
qui surfe actuellement justement
outsider peut-être que ça pourrait
l'aider briquet sur cette rencontre
va-t-il vous le pensez outsider me petit
poucet d'argent parce que c'est normal
ils ont effacé leurs gains pour le coup
je pense que le match va être beaucoup
plus simple pour eux de jouer face à
nantes que face à la cfa ce que je pense
aussi qu'ils ont ils ont un demi sourire
gagné qu'un plus grand nombre de cas
d'un autre côté quand même c'est quand
même le seul sport collectif en france
nous football où on voit une équipe avec
quatre ou cinq niveaux de différence
pouvoir gagner des autres c'est là c'est
la magie mais même même surpris le coupe
de france de handball un volet en cours
- en rugby avec cinq divisions d'écart
vous pourriez jouer cinq fois ou échange
on avait discuté sur ce plateau j'avais
émis
l'hypothèse sur le pourquoi du comment
de cette magie du football sait que le
seul sport qu on n'est pas obligé
d'attaquer la cible donc à partir de là
on n'est pas venu de se confronter à un
adversaire direct donc le lait le niveau
ne n'est pas obligé de se confronter
directement du coup on peut on peut
procéder en compte on peut se regroupent
et on peut et puis c'est un sport avec
non non devient facile d'attaquer la
cible au rugby avec lui non plus tu peux
garder la balle dans ton corps pendant
les équipes vont se rencontrer lundi la
glaciale soutien c'est pas possible
c'est c'est impossible
jean rugby on peut vraiment garder le
ballon et défendre à onze
voilà on peut et en plus comme c'est un
sport où il ya peu de points ou 2 buts
ou fonction des sports bah forcément on
peut les carrés est pas important en bas
il ya 50 ans jules adversaire idéal
alexandre avec la dette la terre salades
elle peut-être je pense qu'arriver à ce
stade là pour eux étant donné qu'ils
vont pas viser le gac de france je pense
que c'est enfin il rencontre une équipe
de ligue 1 ils vont pouvoir faire un
grand spectacle gagner de l'argent et
puis en plus peut-être peut-être pas si
moi je moi je reste persuadé qu'ils ont
une chance pas ça va permettre
l'émergence objecteurs sur le club et je
rapport à la billetterie basit pour
l'anecdote pour l'instant le parcours de
menthe
c'est sept matches gagnés 19 buts
marqués 0 encaissé depuis le rendre à
son gardien de but en coupe de france
soir voilà sur ce thème alexandre après
donc cette page coupe de france on passe
maintenant la rubrique j'aime j'aime pas
de base il a rigolé
donc notre chroniqueur bazire et colis
le cerveau du sport yvin mois nous
présente ces tops et flops
on commence tout de suite par ailleurs
j'aime pas alors qu'est ce que vous
n'aimez pas vasile alors j'aime pas
cette semaine l'annulation en janvier
2016 du tournoi de tennis futures de
feucherolles ça faisait une quinzaine
d'années qu'il était au calendrier
international
la ligue des yvelines a décidé de ne pas
le reconduire cette saison faute de
budget suffisant pour pouvoir
l'organiser il faut savoir que ce
tournoi c'est ça demande un budget de 60
mille euros environ aujourd'hui
les subventions locales territoriales ou
même fédéral ont baissé donc pour
pouvoir pas prendre de risques au niveau
de la ligue des yvelines ils ont décidé
tout simplement de de l'annuler
définitivement
donc c'est vraiment dommageable parce
que ça permettait à des jeunes joueurs
yvelinois de se confronter à des joueurs
de niveau mondial on sait que sur ces
dernières années il ya des joueurs comme
tsonga marc gicquel ou encore l'espagnol
feliciano lopez qui était passée qui
était passé à feucherolles donc c'est
dommage de savoir qu'il existe qui
n'existe désormais plus qu'un tournoi
futures donc de niveau international
dans le département qui a lieu à un
plaisir à l'automne alors alexandre
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de cette
annulation
là pour le coup je suis d'accord je
trouve ça déplorable mais ça les
incrimine pas forcément le club mais
mais plutôt les collectivités alors
après c'est toujours pareil est ce que
est ce qu'ils peuvent se permettre ou
pas mais mais bon c'est toujours
dommageable quand il ya une annulation
d'un
émond sportif majeur c'est le cas c'est
pas un tournoi club c'est tournoi de la
ligue d une wii ce que vous êtes
d'accord la saison je voulais autant
pour moi que là que la ligue n'est pas
réussie de maintenir ce niveau de jeu
dans ce département il y en a toujours
un mais bon deux c'est quand même mieux
ça laisse deux fois plus de chances aux
jeunes de se montrer et puis ça permet
deux fois plus de vocations à l'issue de
ce genre de tournoi pour les petits donc
voilà c'est dommage a mais maintenant la
question c'est est ce que c'était
évitable ça je n'ai pas la réponse on
voit ça va non je pense que tout a été
dit je pars spécialement suivi non plus
cette affaire donc je les découvertes
très récemment et en même temps
j'entends mes camarades je rejoins ce
que dit ce que dit basile et en même
temps c'est vrai qu'on ne peut que
regretter ce genre de ce genre
d'incident maintenant âgé pas j'ai pas
du tout d'éléments pour pour pour en
dire plus par contre je pense que le
match se jouera probablement à menton
d'après ce que j'ai compris il donne
attention petit avertissement mustapha
donc on passe vu que vous voulez pas
plus développé mustapha on va passer aux
gemmes à présent jingle donc vas-y vous
en avez trop aujourd'hui vous avez aimé
beaucoup de choses hein oui enfin pour
cette émission
on a parlé didier lebon numéro que vous
avez pas par l'émission exactement n'a
parlé de coupe de france on va en
reparler cette fois avec un attaquant
l'avant-centre de chambly ont nationale
qui s'appelle wilfried louisy-daniel il
a mis un triplé ce week-end contre reims
donc chambly à éliminer cette équipe de
ligue 1 de reims il ya des buts de 4
buts à 1 pourquoi pourquoi je parle de
ce joueur puisqu'il est originaire du
département il a grandi à fontenay le
fleury avant de rejoindre aurélien
collin comme aurélien collin il a
rejoint en avait parlé la dernière
émission exactement ensuite il a rejoint
versailles avec aurélien collin et
ils se sont retrouvés justement dans la
même équipe à l'époque à versailles que
vous aviez dans la même équipe en
attaque vous aviez hatem benarfa
wilfried louisy-daniel en défense
aurélien collin donc on connaît le
parcours d'aurélien collin celui d'hatem
ben arfa
voilà aujourd'hui j'ai envie de mettre
en lumière celui de wilfried
louisy-daniel parce qu'ensuite il a
rejoint loin poissy en cfa où il a
explosé 23 buts en 28 matches au cours
d'une saison et ça a été un tremplin
pour lui ces dernières années il est
passé à beauvais il a fait orléans
l'année dernière en ligue 2 là il à
chambly en national donc voilà il est
possible de percer dans le football
comme on avait dit avec lorient colin
sans passer par un centre de formation
il joue en ligue 2 il joue en national
il vit de sa passion
donc bravo à lui et au prochain tour il
va pouvoir se mesurer à ce qui ce lieu
en france parce que ça avec l'olympique
lyonnais qui va se retrouver face à
chambly en ce moment l'olympique
lyonnais peut-être que la défense n'est
pas au top donc peut-être qu'il pourra
marquer un but
vasile pourquoi pourquoi pas on lui
souhaite en tout cas c'est une des
belles histoires de cette coupe de
france 1 gens me sens et vous de voir
des amateurs comme ça et propulsé de sur
le devant de la scène
c'est aussi ça qui fait la magie cette
coupe de france mais ce soir c'est le
propre de la coupe de france de football
et justement permettre à des équipes
d'un niveau nettement inférieur à se
confronter à ce qui vous fait de mieux
dans le football français
donc c'est super bien sportivement je
pense que ça doit être génial à vivre
pour les pour les joueurs et cécile se
trahissent a donné comme ça c'est sûr ça
peut donner peut-être un bon exemple
pour mantes le prochain tour et c'est
une histoire qu'il faut leur donner des
idées
c'est une histoire sa foi qui nous fait
aimer cette coupe de france comme celle
de will france et enfin en fait c'est la
coupe de france qui nous permet de
raconter ce type d'histoire et on aime
bien les histoires général surtout quand
c'est le le petit poucet qui bat qui bat
le géant
donc en fait la coupe de france permet
de raconter cette histoire et on en a
tous les ans
normalement la logique si on écoute
notre ami ya une logique sportive on l'a
vu tout à l'heure
par définition il n'ya pas d'exploit il
ya un leader il
un challenger le leader l'emportent
toujours preuve que non alors on a une
très bonne explication tout à l'heure
sur la notion de cible j'ai appris
quelque chose pour le coup mais voilà
c'est vrai que la coupe de france permet
de raconter des histoires et je crois
que d'ailleurs les journalistes adorent
ce type d'histoire nous on le vit au
quotidien sire que ça soit dans le box
c'est également vrai dans le monde
amateur parce qu'on parle de la coupe de
france
faut savoir que nous jouons tous en
coupe de france il faut que les
téléspectateurs sache que quatre rallyes
fier par exemple droit d'être allemand
s'est inclinée mais d'un cheveu contre
versailles par exemple mais voilà
l'exploit était pas loin mais on l'a
vécue de la même façon avec le même
différentiel donc avec la même les mêmes
émotions et avec les mêmes heures
populaire quand même notre histoire qui
se raconte entre nous donc échoué contre
versailles c'est s incliner devant une
très grosse équipe mais n'est d'avant
c'était même une cfa puisqu'on est allé
jusqu à noisy le sec à l'époque
bref la coupe de france permet de
raconter ce genre d'histoire et non pas
l'inversé
c'est ce qui fait le charme et en même
temps le foot c'est le dépassement de
soi et c'est très bien incarner cela
étant il n'est pas seulement de soi
tous les dimanches sur les stades même
pendant le championnat mais la coupe de
france est très particulier originaire
de front telle furie et donc on a parlé
de rien qu'aux liens colin colin ou
wilfried louisy-daniel il ya également
un autre joueur qui s'appelle rémi gomis
qui joue à nantes c'est l'attaquant de
nantes donc qui viendra ce sera mon
amante donc illégalement et qui est de
la exactement de la même génération que
ces deux joueurs donc une belle
génération dé leur énergie
fleury à fontenay le fleury juste avant
d'aller vers ça je me dis ça trappe mais
c'était pas si longtemps des gens dont
on n'a pas eu le nez sur ce recrutement
ce jour là et on a également un gamin à
trappes
très prometteur parle un petit peu j'en
profite puisque on parle foot rarement
je trouve mais on m'a dit m'a dit est
également en centre de formation de
nantes
il sera probablement une des futures
recrues de ce club c'est parce que
nantes recrute aussi dans des clubs
amateurs et fait le nécessaire pour
aller chercher ce type de pépites qu'on
a il y en a une à trappes
elle est chez elle chez eux et du coup
il faut la garder mostafa annoncé ça
c'est non non c'est pas la vocation d'un
club de garder les gosses au contraire
nous les on les accompagne dans leur
quand ils sont bons sont bons il ya des
idées il ya des endroits où ils peuvent
eux justement ce sur perfect parfait
performer non on retient j'ai des
personnes au contraire les accompagnent
donc on passe maintenant au deuxième
j'aime de basile jingle votre deuxième
j'aime concerne le club de basket ball
trap exactement j'aime les dernières
performances de l'équipe de mostafa el
hafi dix ont connu un début de saison
très compliqué avec un enchaînement de
défaites
alors qu'ils s'étaient expliqués par un
groupe complètement nouveau complètement
bouleversé durant l'intersaison la
mayonnaise est en train de prendre
doucement ils ont terminé le mois
décembre avec deux victoires à domicile
qui l'auront qui leur ont permis de
remonter un petit peu au classement de
se donner un peu d'air
donc on a envie de leur souhaiter que ça
que ça s'arrange chaîne maintenant les
résultats pour pour la suite de la
saison va y avoir un mois de janvier
cruciales façon pour eux dans cette
course au maintien en janvier vous
rencontrez les trois derniers du
classement donc on en saura plus à la
fin du mois sur sur ce que peut espérer
la trappe dans ce championnat de
nationale 3 est-ce que vous approuvez ce
gène de basile c'est une superbe
remontée qui sont en train de faire mais
surtout
de tout 16 ans il me semble que tablette
j'aime pas parce qu'ils avaient enchaîné
beaucoup beaucoup de défaites et d'un
quad et ça change d'avis et des
descentes 6-1 6-7 bien qu'ils ont réussi
à arrêter des quantités extrêmement
gênée versailles n'avaient pour a réussi
à faire justement l'an dernier en
national 3 félicitations au groupe
d'entraîneurs franchement très content
donc la mayonnaise est en train vraiment
de prendre y avait plein nouveaux
joueurs il y avait notamment joey
casseus le pivot est habillé baraka où
le meneur qui ont intégré l'équipe cette
année
l'entraîneur disaient qu'ils aient
serait prêt en octobre
finalement c'est sa société prêt en
octobre ils étaient une méthode est tout
à leur faut battre il faudra du temps
mais c'est surtout que c'est aussi très
caractéristique du d'un management jeu
souvent autour de cette table on parle
également de ce qui se passe en interne
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu des modifications
en termes de management tôt au conseil
d'administration il ya eu des
bonifications sacré quoi qu'on en dise
ddd des bouleversements jusque sur le
terrain
et la mayonnaise doit prendre d'abord
dans les têtes au niveau du conseil
d'administration au niveau des
dirigeants
il ya longtemps ça diffuse seul
entraîneur chez les joueurs et voilà
c'est donc une dynamique complète jean
miss chez vous vous avez connu ce schéma
là où vous avez perdu vos premiers
matches ont eu tout à fait après vous
avez réussi à remonter la pente et
surtout vous n'êtes peut être pas
inquiété en sachant que le recrutement
avait été conséquents et par conséquent
voilà tout simplement la meilleure avait
devait prendre là tous les sports
collectifs il faut un temps d'adaptation
lorsqu'il ya des nouveaux joueurs ou des
nouveaux entraîneurs il faut un temps
d'adaptation
comme pour mettre le jeu en place et je
pense que c'est le propre du sport
collectif et que ça se fait pas d'un
coup de baguette magique et que là à mon
avis mais ils sont peut-être sur une
belle pente ascendante et que j'ai vu
par rapport à leur classement sont pas
du tout des crochets et s'il continue
comme ça peut-être que le jeu là
commence à prendre forme et que ça va
porter ses fruits
très très rapide pas en quoi c'est quand
même fragile intentions basque est non
mais ça va très vite
ça va très vite très vite ça va très
très vite mais mason quand même pas tout
à fait ça non le même le classement je
crois qu'il est deux points entre le 4e
et le dixième t3 lapointe du 1er au 2
points du dernier donc ses fils les
avait annoncé peut-être une montée cette
année que d'être pas cette année mais au
moins l'année prochaine
apparemment il est il est dans les temps
l'habitude de finir ce soit par
définition dans la spirale positive par
définition on y arrive pourquoi c'est
tout à fait possible mais je dis
simplement que là c'est également à
regarder derrière soi c'est aussi très
fragile
mais voilà effectivement à trappes on
aime bien la difficulté à la difficulté
dernier à l'intersaison et ça nous est
arrivé
il le sait mais voilà non c'est pas des
choses qu'on souhaite toutes nos équipes
en deux ans devant et deux ans tout
exploit reste à votre avis genlis ils
vont monter cette année où c'est trop
tard
moustic jaurès appelé j'en ai trois bus
pour savoir si vous montez ou pas à dire
qu'avec le début de saison c'est pas
favorables eux tu es là ils sont encore
une fois sur une pente ascendante
mathématiques mais voilà
mathématiquement tout est possible mais
ça veut pas d'eux c'est ça que je veux
dire c'est qu'à donner quand il ya
quelqu'un devant qui marquent des points
il marque des points faudrait qu'ils ne
marquent plus parce que le différentiel
il existe en leur défaveur
quand il ya un différentiel en leur
défaveur ça tu dépends des autres qui
doivent perdre des points parce que si
tout le monde gagne basse le
différentiel de moeurs
le retard quand tu la gagnes tu cadets
puis le voilà où tu perds quatre mois la
4e match d'affilée
mais ce retard là il est très difficile
il est acquis même si tu gagnes tout
comme moustapha c'est que quand tu es ok
tu commences à gagner mais que les
autres jimmy a gagné mais le record
c'est toujours le même rêve donc c'est
compliqué je précise à apprendre à culoz
le dire il est tout le temps d'accord
donc un damné j'aime basile jingle il
concerne le dakar 2007 je vous laisse la
parole basile oui alors pourquoi le
dakar et bien tout simplement parce que
on parle de sébastien loeb et stéphane
perde petter hansson d nasser al attiyah
ce sont les plus médiatisés mais il faut
savoir qu'on a également de la meilleure
voiture
voilà dans la catégorie voiture on a
deux pilotes yvelinois qui sont engagés
dans cette compétition ils sont amateurs
c'est absolument pas leur leur
profession d'être pilote automobile non
sur des rallyes raids
c'est pour une aventure un défi lycéens
qui se sont lancés donc je pense à jean
pierre garçon qui est originaire de
montesson et jean-philippe theuriau de
la celle saint cloud donc voilà c'est a
eu une aventure humaine qu'ils ont
qu'ils ont envie de vivre maintenant se
lance pas par hasard sur le rallye du
dakar ils ont une certaine expérience
automobile sur d'autres courses qui leur
permet d'aller se lancer sur cette
aventure
donc voilà j'avais envie de mettre en
avant ce beau défi pour ces deux
amateurs du département
mais à huit la gazette du nain la voile
alors vous votez est ce que vous trouvez
cela courageux de participer au dakar
vous votez ça va mal mais comment voter
de partager
tous les a tous les âmes et courageux le
fait d'être courageux quoi j'ai l'accord
non je mens bon on fait un petit duel
entre moustapha et genlis vous commencez
oui avec plaisir mais courageux avec
plaisir oui avec plaisir but c'est un
jeu de mon nom je soulignais vont se
gaver pacifiquement par butin d'un
courageux
le dakar c'est quand même une
compétition assez spécifique
il faut comme on l'a dit vasile il faut
quand même une certaine technicité
tout le monde va faire une compétition
comme celle là il faut surtout quand
même un petit peu de financement donc
quand on y va avec des écuries ou là y'a
pas de soucis des sponsors et où je ne
sais pas je ne connais pas ces personnes
là dans le cadre dans lequel elles sont
engagées voevoda car si c'est sur leurs
propres fonds oui effectivement je peux
dire c'est courageux si c'est
si c'est au niveau avec des partenaires
des sponsors sur sur cette discipline
pourquoi pas après sur la discipline le
même c'est plus c'est plus une
une aventure une aventure humaine énorme
pour connaître certaines personnes qui
alors qu'ils ont fait mais je dirais pas
que c'est un courage qu'on s'était dit
pas que c'est le courage c'est plus une
aventure et je pense que ces jeunes qui
vont qui vont faire le dakar c'est
vraiment le goût de la voiture donc
c'est plus puisqu'une avis m plaisir que
que tu n'as que que encourage mustapha à
dire le contraire mais en fait on est on
est on est d'accord puisque oui ça c'est
que en l'occurrence tous les sports
party moment on en est passionné on est
passé de son sport il ya plus de notion
de courage à pratiquer le sport qu'on
aime c'est pas le mien ça serait à la
limite complètement extraordinaire de me
voir faire moi le dakar c'est pas mon
sport c'est pas ma discipline ma
prédilection dont vous rêvez toujours et
1016 mais ça mais c'est leur score c'est
lors discipline c'est vraiment leur
vocation
moi qui a plus de notion de courage a
participé et finalement la compétition
qui caractérise ce qui caractérise votre
sport et votre passion c'est juste que
voilà après comme dans tous les sports
on veut vouloir être devant et quand on
est les deux vont prend des risques
séances à qu'effectivement c'est
courageux c'est en ça que c'est
courageux parce que quand on prend des
risques on va vraiment au fond et
j'avais dire à fond et là par définition
de prendre des risques on fait même
prendre des risques parce qu'on parle du
dakar il ya du monde sur la route il ya
des morts alors je sais pas si on peut
dire qu'il ya des morts tous les ans
mais globalement c'est un peu ce que je
retiens quand même il ya quand même une
victime soit parmi les concurrents ce
soit par les jeux parmi les gens qui qui
sont sur le bord de la route et donc
ouais ya une forme de courage à aller
faire ce type de sport à partir du
moment où on veut premier comprend un
type de risques parce que sinon c'est
une course de bagnoles et on sait un
torrent bagnols quoi à limite moi je
pourrais le faire avec la clim dedans et
je finis dernier s'est juste fait un
tour en bagnole vous engagez mais alpha
mos table si c'est pour le faire comme
certains se plaisent il ya des pare
brises
les barrières horaires il ya des
barrières horaires sur chaque étape
facile à éliminer si on n'est pas gâté
les iai est doué c'est pas juste une
mi-temps mais mustapha sera les trois
premières manches ça c'est à dire que
dans tous les cantons n'ont engagé dans
sa passion c'est plus une forme de
courage c'est vraiment et ambitionner le
fonds sud dakar c'est pas la version
automobile la plus dangereuse que voilà
je pense que le rallye va beaucoup plus
vite beaucoup plus proche des sorties de
route la formule 1 aussi
donc voilà je pense que c'est quand même
je pense que courage ça va avec
dangerosité et est mort koala à la fin
c'est là où vraiment falloir du courage
ou ou aussi des sports où on va être
isolé je pense aux sports de voile
on va être isolé pendant un certain
temps est donc en bas bon désolé
l'accent de vous couper on va passer à
vos thèmes suivants donc après cette
rubrique j'aime j'aime pas on passe
maintenant notre focus du jour il
concerne le sport automobile
donc aujourd'hui notre focus concerne le
sport automobile williams bertrand 13
ans et déjà un as du volant sans son
permis en poche
ce jeune sportif né au chesnay font
aujourd'hui partie des trois meilleurs
jeunes pilotes de kart de l'hexagone
dans la catégorie cadets où il ya
bertrand remporté le sens trophy 2015 et
a terminé la deuxième place 2 au
championnat d'île de france au total
willy comme le surnomment ses parents
réalisé huit podiums sur les 12 douze
courses qu'il a disputées cette saison
nous l'avions rencontré sur le circuit
d'angerville bref c'est d'être en f1
mais c'est très difficile et donc pas
déjà être en automobile ces c'est déjà
bien mais c'est pour ça que
parallèlement je vais à l'école j'ai des
très bons résultats pour m'assurer la
nation et une grande maîtrise il a une
grande intelligence de la course il
arrive à maîtriser les compétitions à
savoir se repositionner pendant la
course
récemment dans un championnat de france
il fallait faire attention à la gestion
des pneumatiques il a su justement ne
pas toujours attaquer à la limite pour
pouvoir préserver la machine et espérer
être mieux dans la fin de la compétition
être bon à 13 ans doit-il forcément dire
que william bertrand ce sera le futur à
michael schumacher vous votez oui non à
tous non d'accord ok pas de duel vasile
pu continuer là encore on avait pas mal
match photo vous êtes ses filets en
chaleur mais sa part au symposium basile
à votre avis du coup on ne sait pas qui
peut devenir le nouveau michael
schumacher en sweat maintenant c'est
prématuré
vous êtes bien c'est bien photo et la
route est longue et surtout en bagnole
ouais je souligne chaque fois mois
non mais ça c'est trop trop thomas pas
être le pire le kart c'est une
discipline après la formule 3 3000 san
et une autre est la formule est c'est
encore autre chose
beaucoup d'états donc là je crois que
c'est comme laisser quoi me donne toutes
les disciplines on dirait enfin un
garçon de 13 ans qui joue dans n'importe
quel sport on dirait bien ce sera le
futur grand champion de sa discipline
il ya tellement de paramètres qui
rentrent en cause serait pas mature et
qu'il ya encore plus en formule 1 ouais
c'est que chaque vin place sur le
service web contraire cela est apparu
dans le cursus et requins journée vaut
mieux être veut mais bon à son âge
plutôt que ne pas savoir tenir sa de
tenir la route
rien donc il est dans le cursus ont valu
souhaitait effectivement tous les
paramètres sont là je vais réussir ma
phrase si tu veux bien mais par le passé
il faut à vous dire un truc à part dire
un truc c'est que voilà on a l'habitude
de rencontrer nos enfants et est souvent
moi je les vois dans leur attitude dans
le football j'entends jeu par un
spécialiste un technicien du football et
de la surface il a une super attitude
par contre ça marquerait la fin à treize
ans la face on ne dit pas la façon
qu'ils présentent les choses de façon de
retrouver mature je lui trouve une
grande maturité il manie les mots là on
va dire une drive attitude mais aurait
dû faire la politique
bientôt nous savent pas comment comment
on réagit quand on a un talent brut
comme ça comment comment le façonnent ce
diamant vous savez comment on se tourne
vers man il ya des choses intéressantes
c'est à dire donc je vais continuer s'il
veut bien mais non pareil que dans le
foot je disais tout à l'heure j'ai mon
manager général qui a l'habitude de dire
des choses excessives manseng mais
excessivement vrai c'est quand il est
bon il est bon et donc on façonne pas il
ya un talent brut
en revanche il ya toute une technicité
affaires à faire apparaître donc nous
notre métier c'est de faire apparaître
la technicité de l'accompagner mais ce
talent
l'élément brut il là on l'accompagnent
en revanche on est là pour apporter et
l'accompagner alexandre vous faites
comment pour pour façonner ses diamants
je voudrais répondre sur autre chose
tout bann à dire que il fait du cac dont
la blessure n'est pas un facteur n'est
pas un frein dans sa possibilité de
d'être un des jeunes ont fait des zones
mortes
ce ne sera pas un frein à une blessure
éventuelle mais en plus on voit comment
il peut se blesser a feinté dans la vie
de tous les jours pour sa carrière que
dans d'autres sports on sait très bien
qu'un jeune se décentrer tôt en plus
très tôt c'est encore beaucoup plus
grave que qu'une fois qu'on est pro donc
en pleine croissance et c'est quasi
rédhibitoire
donc du coup voilà au moins hélas
avantage là dans ce sport à
il ay la pratique pas un sport où il ya
un risque de blessure donc déjà ras et
puis comme comme le dit moustafa il est
dans la boucle
mais maintenant comme entre l'afld de
cartes et de la formule 1 il ya quand
même un monde et c'est pas plus que s'il
n'y a pas plus qu'un nom quoi je sais
pas combien
donc on peut pas impossible de dire que
quelqu'un qui est bon en carte sera bon
formule 1 c'est impossible
et puis nous écoute je voudrais pas
qu'il pense qu'effectivement ces acquis
à sagelat faut surtout pas qu'ils
pensent que c'est sûr ça le vrai débat
savoir nous c'est ramener toujours à de
la modestie ramener les choses à leur
juste réalité
en fait ces deux là c'est là qu'on les
accompagne son facebook voilà il ya
c'est prometteur
y aller tu continues mais voilà il ya
encore des étapes à franchir
donc vous qui ne connaissaient pas ou
william bertrand on regarde cette petite
séquence petit jeu s'appelle le dilemme
quatre en compétition
michael chemin
cina
ferrari
circuit monaco
benchikha
frêche
genlis mais ça fait le disais tout à
l'heure on a l'impression que c'est un
pro quasiment là on voit dans sa
maturité
non vous trouvez pas l'once moi je pense
que c'est la fin de son âge tout
simplement parce que les réponses a les
réponses
moi je suis juste une réponse rush
michel voyage sûrs qu'il sait pas ce que
c'est lui qui est le meilleur
mais bon c'est pas méchant ce que c'est
parce qu'il sait pas qui arrache non
plus je connais les deux mais non mais
c'est vrai qu'il a il a des réponses de
la nationale et comme j comme disait
mustapha deuxième fois je suis d'accord
avec toi sur 200 mais c'est vrai que
voilà il faut pas que ça devienne une
habitude et il est jeune il a beaucoup
il a tout à apprendre
il a tout à apprendre et encore une fois
on va se répéter mais il ya un monde
il ya un monde il est bon en karting
c'est bien qu'ils continuent comme ça
après j'avais boulot est issu d'un pas
tellement de ce qu'il dit ce qui peut
prononcer parce qu'il a effectivement
vous avez complètement raison parce qu
on se vouvoie au plateau mais vous avez
complètement raison
il a les propos du gamin mais je trouve
qu'il a une attitude quelque chose on ne
parle pas c'est non verbale en tout cas
on les souhaite d'avoir une belle et
longue carrière dans ce sport on passe à
présent notre rubrique débats
notre premier débat concerne le 4l
trophy la 19e édition est programmée du
18 au 28 février prochain cette année
plus de 1300 équipages composés
exclusivement d'étudiants se sont
inscrits à la compétition cette année
une lui en courtoise laetitia d'élan de
prendre le départ de cette course qui
relie la france au maroc
le 4l trophy est il une véritable
compétition sportive
on écoute l'avis des yvelinois on ne
peut plus peu moins que nous et c'est
plutôt une performance individuelle
rallye entre guillemets pas vraiment
humanitaire peut-être non parce que
c'est pas le but de gagner c
d'apporter des choses à des enfants qui
en ont besoin donc qu'on arrive premier
qu'on arrive dernier on apporte toujours
ce dont ils ont besoin en tout cas
minimum je pense pas que ce soit une
complète je ne pense pas qu'il faille
que ça devienne ils vont paître
non je pense pas mais c'est d'une course
pour l'amitié la solidarité je pense le
4l trophy est elle une véritable
compétition sportive vous votez oui non
non d'accord tout mon tourner encore
vous avez décidément météo aujourd'hui
comme basile alors pourquoi ce n'est pas
une véritable compétition sportive parce
qu'il ya et il n'y a pas vraiment de
zouk classement il ya ba ya pas de coup
il n'y a pas de chrono on y va avant
pour un pour un défi par un défi
personnel pour une aventure pour voilà
parce qu'ils se disent qu'après ya quand
même d'accord il ya quand même et en
tête de course quand même vas-y oui à
tour à un promu
du premier au dernier ouais mais je ne
pense pas que c'est l'objectif premier
que qu'on recherche en s'inscrivant sur
ce support je suis un être humain de
course avant tout à ses mémoires tuerie
mais le film en le moralisant a fait que
j'ai fait un rallye moi c'était à
versailles pendant celle rock dans les
soirées mondaines
donc c'est tout ça que ça me fait penser
à ces voix là on y va aussi parce qu'il
ya
on a changé le groupe il ya un groupe
c'est qu'il ya quoi il ya 1300 203 sans
avoir jamais compté parmi 300 g pas
retenu bien sûr mais j'ai partout le
chiffre exact merci de me le dire
mais voilà donc si il y à aussi plus
peut-être l'impression aussi que c'est
un événement moi je suis un peu gêné
pour tout vous dire sur ce type de
rattrapage et newey sur ce type d'
aventure il ya un côté on parle d'
humanitaires je sais pas trop ce que ça
apporte en humanité réel donc c'est des
fournitures ou sept camions ils
arriveront de la même façon ils sont
redistribuées c'est je vois pas bien on
se donne bonne conscience plutôt en
apportant ce type de choses pour les
rites pour les distribuer plus franck
bonne conscience on peut les envoyer
autrement ensuite il ya ce côté on parle
alors le sport c'est une chose mais là
j'ai vraiment l'impression que sur le
sur le bilan carbone
le travaillement qu'ils ont aussi bonne
conscience à dire que ils vont donner
pour des panneaux solaires de choses
comme ça pour se donner bonne conscience
mais il ya quelque chose qui me gène
voilà c'est juste que toutes ces
bagnoles déversés dans des territoires
aussi magnifique que vous pouvez
l'imaginer
déjà le dakar c'est un peu limite j'en
ai pas parlé tout à l'heure mais c'est
un peu limite déjà mais bon vous plaît
pas du tout la non je suis un peu gêné
un bac arts voitures électriques comme
j'étais un peu jeune mais l'autonomie
n'est pas donc en tout cas livi noise
laetitia des landes s'entraîne dur
mostafa pour cette compétition elle a
créé une stratégie pour son périple un
conte à 6000 km à faire pendant dix
jours
du coup ça fait une moyenne de 600
kilomètres par jour donc on va alterner
voilà des qualités fatigue et hop on
alterne et puis après bah oui on va
vivre ensemble au quotidien on aura une
petite tente donc on va dormir ensemble
tous les soirs sous la tente
on va tourner régulièrement peut-être
trois heures chacune
à chaque fois pour pour se répartir le
temps pour éviter cette fatigue juste
avant bon alexandre et ne font pas
pareil que pour rigoler ans
les deux sont à l'antenne non non vous
rigolez mais c'est encore heureux
puisqu'ils font laventure c'est quand
même c'est pas c'est pas rien non plus
elle vise le haut du classement
oui mais s'aimer encore au moins si je
faisais une aventure comme ça j'ai un
esprit compétiteur je viserai la
première place mais mais c'est pas pour
autant que c'est quelque chose de
professionnel n'y a pas de
professionnels c'est pas et puis après
là on a pris l'exemple de de ces
personnes là mais c'est pas forcément le
cas à mon avis de tous les participants
ne vise pas tous à être premier
je ne pense pas s'aventurer mère
j'espère que 1300 membres est devant
nancy là on a bien vu la préparation
c'est quand même la cantine
voilà l'intendant ce tissu revoilà sur
le campement pour moi quand on fait une
compétition c'est on connaît son ou ses
adversaires là pour concurrencer
connaissent pas les concurrents contre
qu'il y ait qui vont ce pognon c'est
l'époque des bas belleville
donc après le 4l trophy en passe au
rugby donc l'équipe de plaisir caracole
en tête de la poule de fédérale 3 c'est
pour vous fournissent les pzero affiche
un bilan de 8 victoires et une seule
défaite depuis le début de la saison je
me trompe à genlis c'est ça et plaisir à
marquer 273 points cette année et en a
encaissé seulement 73 s à l'équipe de
plaisir peut-elle devenir la meilleure
équipe du département où est elle tout
simplement la meilleure épartement vous
pouvez voter en genlis
on va on va voter juste après le
classement comme on peut le voir
classement il a justement valu en tête
donc je désire peut-être devenir la
meilleure équipe du département où est
elle tout simplement la meilleure équipe
du département vous votez oui les airs
vous êtes la bonne question mais cette
fois-là de la scission c'est quoi les
mois j'étais à 10m question pas d'accord
si on peut-être de l'est tel est elle
actuellement est elle si le débat bon
j'en lis je me rabats pour l'instant à
basile contre alexandre total est parti
tout à l'heure on parlait de foot et de
division deux clubs de khl à de
classement en rugby ça si on fait un si
on regarde le classement de fédérale 3 /
sur l'année 2015 ce qui vient de se
terminer
plaisir et dans le dos le haut de
tableau versailles dans sa poule et dans
le bas du classement
c'est également le cas du duo mlsgp
maisons laffitte saint jean a indiqué
dans la même poule que plaisir voici
donc si on suit au classement sachant
qu'il n'y a pas d'autres équipes
yvelinoise en plus on fédérale 2 où
fédéral une
actuellement ces plaisirs qui domine qui
domine sur cette saison les débats avec
moi en tant qu'entraîneur je n'aime pas
dire ce genre de choses tant que le
championnat n'est pas terminé
donc voilà pour moi peut-elle oui et
elle non on verra à la fin de la saison
ouais mais dans ce cas dans ce cas on
arrête toutes nos émissions quoi parce
qu'à un moment donné il faut qu on se
mouille aussi c'est à dire que je suis
d'accord avec millions techniquement
mais à un moment donné c'est vrai qu'il
faut dire les choses c'est la meilleure
équipe du département
il est devant maintenant et on ne se
sera jamais de le dire et puisque vous
êtes compétiteurs la compétition c'est
ça il est devant il va rester devant
c'est le meilleur moment et il sera
meilleur bah c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne et on se donne les moyens
pour que ce soit comme ça
alors après pour le reste oui le plein
de choses maintenant s'incliner devant
ce que la vie peut éventuellement
produire mais voilà pour le moment plus
en plus il est là pour la question je ne
pense pas à causer agents à jean michel
est présent aujourd'hui c'est quel est
le projet plus ou moins long terme de
plaisir
en rugby est ce que c'est parce que l'on
fédérale 2 de se stabiliser de devenir
justement l'équipe fleuron du
département alors je vais essayer de
répondre à deux questions
moi je sens que moi j'ai répondu jeudi
répondu japonais à être détendu question
en disant qu' on est actuellement la
meilleure équipe du département et ça
c'est les résultats qu'il le montre
c'est pas moi qui ai mal factuel et que
bon on peut parler de début comme tout à
l'heure avec le basket de début et de
fin de saison
là il se trouve qu'un conte à 36 points
d'avance / / / maisons laffitte
on est premier et son dernier les aurait
levé 2 qui était à l'époque nous
inquiéter et qui était le plus d'aidés
nord est où les a évalués dans les
aventures de long de nombreuses années
la meilleure équipe du département et
avec renault c'est pour ça que je dis
qu'aujourd'hui oui on est la meilleure
équipe parce que le classement est là
pour nous le terrain est ce qu'on va
devenir la meilleure équipe
ça va tellement vite la preuve en est
ces maisons laffitte on vient d'en
parler juste à l'esa ces maisons
laffitte est bizarre
fit la saison dernière jouer quasiment
les haut de tableau de la fédérale 2
donc aujourd'hui ils soient mal au
tableau de fédérale 3 ça va très très
vite comme tous les sports et comme tous
les clubs on maîtrise pas tous les
éléments d'un club
quel que soit le sport est aujourd'hui
mais on est beau aujourd'hui et demain
on peut être très vilain donc le
problème c'est qu'on n'a pas tous les
fans et les facteurs qui peuvent eux qui
peuvent nous permettre de dire on sera
toujours le meilleur non l'actuel avoir
violé la réponse pour pour basile je
vais vous la réponse je vous la donne et
c'est que le projet bien sûr que le
projet du club c'est de remonter en
fédérale 2 puisque la saison dernière un
plaisir évoluer en fédérale 2 est
descendu sur la dernière journée
simplement sur la dernière journée donc
ils ont failli se maintenir
donc je pense que toute une expérience
moi je suis arrivé cette saison c'est
une expérience qu'ils ont vécu à ce
niveau-là dont ils ont ils ont tiré
bien sûr des leçons et ça c'est très
important je pense qu'aujourd'hui bien
sûr l'objectif du club c'est de remonter
le plus rapidement possible mais surtout
après de s'y maintenir de s'y maintenir
et là il ya quand même un gros travail
et c'est pour ça qu'à l'intersaison il
ya eu quand même aussi comme un
recrutement dans cet objectif et que
effectivement les parties on est parti
pour mais hélas le chemin est arrivé
vous aide dans ce projet oui la
municipalité oui la municipalité est
très proche d'eux
de nous est très très proche du club
c'est une ville très sportive plaisir
j'ai pas caché à personne je confiant
autour de la table c'est une ville très
sportive et la municipalité est très
proche de nous mais le sport c'est le
sport et comme on parlait tout à l'heure
de la coupe de france
là la montée un match de rugby c'est un
match de rugby
même si c'est sous forme d'aller retour
il faut passer deux tours en match aller
retour
elle n'est jamais acquis données
acquises et par dessus de la fédérale 2
et la federal une qui la troisième des
troisième échelon national
oui maintenant c'est presque
professionnel la fédérale une ou
semi-professionnels cédant certaines
équipes
est ce qu'un jour on pourrait espérer
voir un club yvelinois évolué en enfer
confédéral une parce que c'est pas léger
alors est en flammes aujourd'hui même
aujourd'hui je serais thales afin que la
fédérale 2 au jour d'aujourd'hui il ya
certaines équipes ce sont des écuries
professionnelles
prenez des clubs qu'on rouen premier
club comme chalon quand ils sont passés
jeanneret sur ce sont des clubs qui sont
professionnels ils ont des joueurs
étrangers avec sous contrat
professionnel en fédérale 2 et ensuite
il ya un fossé entre la fédérale 3 la
fédérale 2 et il ya un ravin entre la
fédérale 2 la fédérale une haie de
lauriers après c
c'est le désert entre la fédérale une et
le la pro d2 donc plus on monte plus
l'écart est important
monté en général une déjà commandé en
fédérale 2 quand s'y maintiennent ce
sera très très bien fraîcheur donc après
ce débat sur le rugby on passe à notre
défi du jour le défi concerne
aujourd'hui le rugby les joueurs du sky
rugby doivent toucher les poteaux de 25
mètres pour remporter la victoire les
gagne le gagnant est celui qui réussit à
toucher en premier les poteaux on
regarde la séquence
jérémy barbier j'habite à l encours et
mon surnom c'est chicken le flou et
rions j'habite à versailles et ont su
renoncer loulou l'oeil thibault j'habite
à l encours et mons ont dansé mayonnaise
au noyau julien henriot bérès j'habite à
hull en cours et mon surnom c'est
mayonnaise de maillots gauthier alexis
j'habite bucs et mon surnom ses vieilles
que nous
et
ok
en fait
mais
le père john yoo
c'est pas du tout au top même on peut le
dire parce que à part à l'échauffement
mais on a réussi à toucher un peu la
barre sinon pour la compétition avait
plus personne
et du coup ces kits au vainqueur
vainqueur ce soir c'est louis qui a
réussi à toucher là bas à l'échauffement
uniquement malheureusement et c'est
difficile oui alors vous pourrez pas
simple je pense que le froid a eu raison
de nous et on bon on espère faire mieux
sur le prochain défi jour miss c'est si
difficile que ça de toucher à les photos
au rugby oui sauf que sauf que les
professionnels ça traîne a avisé les
poteaux invité à viser les poteaux entre
écolos et non mais un c'est une des
formes d'entraînement et à plaisir vous
êtes meilleur que lorsqu'elle rugby
ouais et logiquement vous êtes la vérité
je vois là et on a 10 pour les sages
veut pas dire qu'il faut pas céder
il faut une technique particulière et
c'est pas pour pour tirer justement il
faut faire de la drees c'est quoi votre
astuce de la chaise mais grave de la
chaise parce que franchement l'avancé
des séquences qu'on est resté à peu près
une demi heure mais non mais il soit il
soit avec m des travées mètres face aux
poteaux et la distance et abuse l'appui
16 que le ballon retombe sur la barre
transversale
il ya quand même un gros facteur chanois
alexandre vous pouvez pas vous moquez
vous n'avez pas touché du tout la barre
transversale en quoi 10 tentatives qu'un
centre j'ai touché deux fois
l'entraînement et dans les trois
tentatives en direct j'ai pas cherché on
a pas la vidéo de l'intégralité des tirs
de ce que je peux vous la passe et
l'asie
mais les téléspectateurs sont souligné
que mes joueurs de foot eux par contre
entre savent tirer au pied donc les
footballeurs sont meilleures qu'au lait
à herbie mann sais je voulais te dire
c'est pas la même base mais en même
temps c'est pas leur boulot de taper de
la barbe non plus ni au foot c'est la
fin de cette émission merci nous avoir
suivi on se retrouve le jeudi à 21
janvier un petit message à sa femme si
c'est bien sûr sa williams et guillaume
qui est et qui n'étaient pas présents
sur cette émission mais qui sont là
sûrement sur les prochaines voilà je
vous rassure un bon taf un bon jeu sur
la fin de cette émission merci de nous
avoir suivi on se retrouve le jeudi 21
janvier pour un nouveau nouveau numéro
de six ans par les sports à bientôt et
encore une très bonne année